38 million people used to watch american
idol when paul abdul was a judge
and she just reminded us why she was
such a big head she's great tv now you
never know what she's going to say and
our lauren zema spoke with paula after
she
nearly stopped the show filling in for
luke bryan
anything goes tonight paula what was it
like for you you reunited with ryan then
randy facetime
and then then you called simon an std so
we're just missing the
std the the what sexy
talented and definite i'm so happy you
cleared that up thank you
so much do you think you'll hear from
simon after tonight
i have no idea how did it feel for you
to be up there again paula
it was nostalgic it was fun i loved
being
on this panel with this panel tonight
it's way different than the panel i was
on that's for sure
e.t was with paula and the og crew in
the beginning
simon's the one that makes them usually
walk out crying
when paula's love-hate relationship with
simon help make idol a hit
i didn't have to go to therapy before
tonight
[Laughter]
you saved the show tonight paula who
told us she received her second coveted
vaccine on saturday
stepped in last minute for judge luke
bryan he tested positive for cobit 19.
katie did you all talk to luke yeah he
was texting us he was blowing up our
phones
the whole some of it we can't even say
because we can't say half of it
um but he agreed with everything and you
know he was just giving critiques
at home i guess alone in his room
is he feeling okay how is he yeah he's
totally good
i think he's gonna be all right i think
we'll be seeing him next week
yeah even though we love paula and there
was another idle twist last night
finalist wyatt pike had to drop out
we're told front-runner wyatt
left for personal reasons the
contestants are noun down to the top 12.
as for paula's mini idol reunion well it
wasn't the only reason she was feeling
nostalgic
we saw janet jackson sent you some love
on social media today
she just said sending love to you with
this great picture of you two
talk about going back like from my
humble beginnings
[Music]
the former laker girl choreographed
several videos for janet in the mid-80s
paula do you and janet keep in touch yes
we do